serena williams won her first u.s open
match in what is expected to be the
final professional tennis tournament of
her historic career
the tennis legend went head to head with
dr kovanich in front of this sold out
star-studded crowd in new york city's
arthur ashe stadium and came out on top
winning six to three sending her through
to the second round and beyonce is
paying tribute to serena's remarkable
career narrating a new gatorade ad
honoring her inspiration to everyone
especially young women of color take a
look we'll see you next time
[Applause]
when the world writes her down in
history
we'll begin where she started
at love
[Music]
no points
zero score
[Music]
just love
it's a love that will remember through
the generations
a love that started a movement a
movement to always love exactly who you
are and who you can be to be so in love
with your identity that your very
essence cannot be contained
to love the sound of your own voice
and the way you move
to feel like a queen unapologetically
with the crown indefinitely
to cherish every muscle and every curve
your body exhibits
a movement to always love being a proud
black woman
a parent
a dreamer
a leader yes it can be to love being one
of a kind
to always love being you
the whole you
the real you
you
you
you
to always love
you
so when we write her down in history no
matter who you are no matter where you
are
we'll remember what she's shown us
a movement
to love
you